All right, so you have the app in front of you now.
Your first task will be to add a new recurring expense
and split it among household members.
So please begin.
Once you get to the point, the expense in question
is a rent expense.
Let's say it's about $1,200.
The date is maybe the 31st of March.
And let's say you want to repeat it weekly.
And select the three household members that it applies to.
Just tell me when you feel you're done.
OK, I'm done.
Should I click Create?
Yes.
Can you just voice what's happening now?
OK, I can't seem to click on the Create button
to go to the next page, I guess.
Could you put something in the description for me?
Can I type it?
I don't think you can.
OK, that's broken.
Take my breaks.
Interesting.
OK, I'm scrolling out.
Cancel out of here.
OK.
Do you want to just quickly try and do that again?
Sure.
Please can.
Let's see if it doesn't break.
Name, category, let's go rent.
$1,200, 31st of March, weekly, three household members.
Maybe just try and put a description in there.
Oh, OK.
I think I was waiting for the description.
OK, and just press Create.
And interesting, it reset the rent and amount and repeat.
No, it is not.
Do you want to just add Sam again?
Oh, never mind.
It's not even reset them.
It's jumped to cheese.
Oh, I think it's because you made a new expense.
All right, we're going to cancel the,
yeah, we can stop the screen recording there, I think.
That's fine.
Just continue with the next task.
Yeah, no, for the other task.
All right, we'll continue with the next task,
which is to pay an existing expense
and then confirm that it's been removed.
So the expense in question is an expense that Alex has paid
and that you need to now pay him for, them, them for.
That was the power expense, about $80 or so, probably.
Can you verify that that exists?
Oh, food?
Yeah.
Food is $80.
Rent is that much.
Do you want to try expanding?
Yes.
Yes, there we go.
$80.
Perfect.
Can you pay that for me?
Can you confirm, has it been paid?
Should I go back to the home page?
If you'd like to.
Because I'm not sure what's going on.
Fair enough.
I still have the power?
OK, no worries.
That's all right.
That's fine.
We'll continue with the next task.
Right, yes, that's right.
Talk more about what's going on.
Yes, feel free to voice what's happening, your confusions,
your concerns, what's happening in general, what you tried to do,
what happened instead, that kind of thing.
So in this case, you.
Well, I tried to pay the power.
And it disappeared from the pay section.
Well, it's still here.
But when you went to the home page, it was still there.
I'm not 100% sure whether it did pay.
Could you jump over to the pay section and check for me?
Yes.
Is it there still?
It's the first one, yeah.
All right, good to know.
Should I click the pay button again?
No, let's move on to the next task.
OK, I'll go back to home now.
Sounds good.
All right, next up, I'd like you to look at a past expense.
Let's say garbage from last week.
And can you just tell me who paid that garbage expense
last week?
First, should I go to expense tab?
You say you want to go to the expense tab, OK.
And then what do you want to do?
The past week.
Is that what you said?
Yes, last week.
Last week.
So garbage was 380, flatmate person one and person two.
Awesome.
Thank you very much.
So flatmate person one and person two.
All right, thank you very much.
The next task is to, I'd like you
to look at the insights for rent over the past month or so,
or just look at the monthly insights for rent.
And just tell me what you think of it.
What do you see?
Well, I see a pie chart, which clearly describes rent
being 70% of my expenses, and it totaling to $1,800 monthly.
OK, good to know.
Can we move on to task five?
Sorry, do we want to have her correct or not?
OK.
Do we want to move on to task five?
Task five is, I'd like you to enable,
I'd like you to adjust the color scheme of the app,
and maybe the contrast too, if you'd like.
And just sort of talk about what
you're doing as you're doing that, what the outcome is.
Let's go back.
OK, I went to the, when I go to the, oh, what's up here?
Clicked on the navigation three bars.
Went to app settings, display settings,
and assume I can go to the dark mode.
Oh, shit, that's pretty cool.
OK.
And high contrast, oh, wow.
That's pretty cool.
What does system mean?
Is it just like?
OK, good to know.
Typically, the system, the app, the mobile device
is either set to dock or level, so we
can try and learn from that.
So then shouldn't that be the default one?
That's some very useful feedback, thank you.
All right, but can you just change some settings
and tell me what you changed and what you think of it?
Contact and support.
I can.
Sorry, I meant accessibility settings.
Oh, accessibility.
Yes.
That you changed.
Oh, the color themes.
Just need to read.
Yes.
Well, I changed to dark mode and to high contrast.
All right, and do those work well?
Yes, those work well.
Visibly changed across the page.
Awesome.
We'll move on to the next task now,
which is I'd like you to get some help from the app.
I'd like you to go and see the FAQ section, perhaps,
and have a look at some of the frequently asked questions.
OK.
I'm on the frequently asked questions,
and I can click on the questions available
and quickly read through them.
OK.
Well, the first one anyways.
Awesome.
Let's continue.
Let's I'd like you to click on the call.
I'd like you to find contact support
and fill out a support form for me.
Tapped out the first.
I think I've already, hmm, one second.
I can't seem to click on, let me just, like that.
Could I just get you to speak up a little bit
from the microphone, especially since there's background noise?
Yes.
I just changed my whole set up to light mode,
just to see if I can, yep.
So basically, when I was on the dark mode on high contrast,
I couldn't see the name.
OK.
All right, thank you very much.
And now I just click the name, click the email.
OK, could you submit a contact support form for me?
Yeah, I'm just going to click on the message.
I don't know if that types up.
OK, it's sent through.
Could you just confirm that it's been sent through?
Yeah, you just need to smack it a few times.
OK, there you go.
Take my issues.
Yeah.
Sent.
Oh, message sent.
Perfect.
Thank you very much.
And it also has a clear message saying
that I will be able to, like, feed back to you after 24,
48 hours.
Awesome.
Thank you very much.
I believe that is all of the questions, of the tasks.
I will now turn off the recording.
OK.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.